the jurgen experience i remember you
saying that too about
training that you would get up in the
morning and train because you wanted
an edge you wanted to know that you were
training while they were asleep exactly
yeah
i remember thinking that back when i was
doing martial arts i remember reading
that i'm like i want to do that too
i copy a lot of [ __ ] you did well you
always have to have and if and even if
it's not
suits so you have to have and that's
where delusion comes in because
delusion is only delusional when you
don't accomplish the goals of making
your delusions a reality
right that's what it's to lose you know
right you you're just
enforcing your mindset oh yeah to allow
those delusions to be the reality of
your
um assessment now when you're doing this
and you're getting up in the morning
and running does this like do you feel
like you felt in the old days do you i
mean i don't mean physically i mean the
mind
like you're preparing for war again do
you does this
does this like reignite those old
thoughts the way
you were when you were the champ the way
you were when you're on your way to the
title
like this is a this is a whole new way
of my life you know what's really
interesting
that sometimes um
period it's not real but sometimes i
struggle with the fact that while the
possibility i can really hurt somebody
like you don't want to hurt them
what do you mean but you struggle
struggle with the possibility that you
could hurt them
that is sometimes it's orgasmic
sometimes
yeah like some fights like particularly
like
tyro biggs or someone that you had
problems with
someone that you you had animosity
towards
so when you finally get your hands on
them hey um
what does it mean um when fighting gets
get you erect what does that mean it's a
good question
means you're getting excited yeah so
that that's going through your mind
right now well that's how i get when i
was a kid and i
you know sometimes i get to twinkle the
twinkle
yeah well that's what i'm saying is like
you reached a state
as a human being as a champion as a
ferocious
fighter you reached a state of of
ability
and of accomplishment that very few
humans will ever ever
touch and feel that's why i'm asking you
when you're running
when you're hitting the bag when that
heart's beating again and you know who
you
are you're mike [ __ ] tyson so
when you're doing all this [ __ ] again
you're still mike tyson
those thoughts have got to be burning
inside you again
it's got to be pretty wild i don't know
it's um it's wild but um
i believe it's um it's rightfully so to
be that way and i just know how to
um i don't think i mastered but i just
know how to deal with it
i don't let it overwhelm me no
well of course not but saying that
it gets you orgasmic that's a strange
thing to say
well that's just what i wanted to find
out because you're really bright
and i thought you were figuring no i'm
being very serious no i know
i i know you're being serious but i mean
no one will understand that
other than you like that's your your
mindset
like no one will but i think that like
all the things we were talking about
before the way you drive yourself the
way you push yourself
the way you put yourself into that frame
of mind no one's gonna understand that
other than you
so no one's gonna understand you get an
erection from thinking about hurting
someone
more than you will there has to be fear
based in somewhere
fear-based maybe or
maybe just maybe not fear-based
but maybe embracing the fact that you're
gonna go into this
with everything that you have the chaos
of it all and
and the ultimate goal is to hurt
somebody the ultimate goal is to be
extremely successful
the way you can be extremely successful
the thing you do great
is to crush people so to
have that encompass everything this
fighting is the only thing i don't ask a
lot for um
i just don't ask him for help for that
you don't ask him for help for fighting
because you think you got it no i just
don't think i oh you don't think you
should ask i just don't want
to be involved with that kind of mindset
in our law
so i know you know people do they go to
i just don't i ask them because it's
just
i don't like the way i think and i don't
want god to be
you know involved with the way i think
at that time well this is what's so
interesting to me about you fighting
again because of the conversation that
we had the last time you were here that
you didn't want to reignite your ego
clearly your ego is blazing right now i
mean you're ready to go
well maybe because i um i'm an addict a
former addict and
i'm on a narcotic ring the camera's on
me yeah he's a big narcotic and maybe
right that has something to do with as
well but i like to think it's under
control
until the night of the event yeah the
night of the event
so it's the the addiction will get
purged
with the with the performance
that's why i'm you know i was i was
doing um if you don't mind me to
interrupt for a second i was um
the book that talks to you what they
call it audiobook and it was called
um the gene key
okay this book and the book was
explaining about why
that we are who we are in that
perspective that most of the people like
you and myself and people people just in
general
who is not at that level even anyone
that have a creative mind
is victimized to depression
and the reason is because um when that
created when that moment whatever it is
that causes that creativity is not
fit the proper information that is
successful and that is accepted in
whatever
space of the brain and the mind that
once it wants to be accepted and is not
accepted
it it crumbles does that make sense
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love